♪
PETE: WELCOME BACK.
JUDGES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ORDERING I.C.E. TO RELEASE
HUNDREDS OF IMMIGRANT DETAINEES,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT FACILITIES
IN QUESTION HAVE ZERO CASES OF
COVID-19 N A NEW FOXNEWS.COM
OP-ED, OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS
JUDGES ARE USING COVID-19 AS AN
EXCUSE TO FREE DETAINED
ILLEGALS.
TOM HOMAN, RETIRED I.C.E.
DIRECTOR, AUTHOR OF THE BOOK,
"DEFEND THE BORDER AND SAVE
LIVES."
HE HAVE JOINS US NOW.
TOM, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
GREAT OP-ED.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO READ
IT.
YOU’RE SAYING THESE JUDGES ARE
NEVER MISSING A MOMENT.
THEY’RE POINTING TO THESE
FACILITIES SAYING YOU GOT TO LET
THEM OUT BECAUSE THEY’RE NOT
SOCIAL DISTANCING EVEN THOUGH
THE FACILITIES DON’T HAVE
COVID-19 PROBLEMS?
>> YEAH.
EVEN GOES BEYOND THAT, PETE.
THE JUDGES NOT PAYING ATTENTION
TO WHAT IS GOING ON.
HE DOESN’T KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
AT THE DETENTION FACILITIES.
OUR DETENTION FACILITIES HAVE
THE HIGHEST DETENTION STANDARDS
IN THE INDUSTRY.
OUR PRIVATE CONTRACTORS, OUR
FACILITIES, HAVE TWICE AS
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS THAN ANY
STATE OR LOCAL FACILITY.
THEY’RE DOING TESTING TODAY.
IF SOMEONE BECOMES SYMPTOMATIC
THEY’RE DOING A COVID TEST ON
THEM.
KEEPING THEM COHORT WHEN THEY’RE
DOING THE TEST.
DEALING MORE FROM ILLEGAL ALIENS
IN DETENTION THAN MOST AMERICAN
CITIZENS IN THE PUBLIC.
THEY ARE NOT MAKING RULING OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS THERE ARE ZERO CASES.
JASON:
PETE: THEY JUST WANT THEM OUT
BECAUSE THE GOAL TO BEGIN WITH.
THEY BROKE THE LOU IN FIRST
PLACE BEING HERE ILLEGALLY.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT OTHER CRIMES
AS WELL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IF YOU LOOK RIGHT NOW, WE LEASE
OVER 100 CRIMINALS BECAUSE OF
DECISION OF THE JUDGES.
IN NEW YORK CITY, IT IS A
RELEASE AFTER SUBJECT WHO IS A
RAPE OF A CHILD.
YOU HAVE HAD THREE MURDERS BEEN
RELEASED A PERSON IN
MASSACHUSETTS RELEASED CONVICTED
OF RAPE.
CONGRESSMAN LIKE AOC, CASTRO,
OMAR, CALLING FOR MORE RELEASES.
CONGRESSIONAL HISPANIC CAUCUS
WANTS ILLEGAL ALIENS RELEASED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THESE CONGRESSMAN TURNED BACK ON
VERY LAWS THEY ENACTED, AND THEY
WANT TO VILIFY MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ENFORCE THE LAWS.
PETE: PRO-ILLEGALITY, OPEN
BORDERS CROWD LAY NAKED BEFORE
US.
THEY DON’T WANT ANY FACILITIES
AT ALL AS WE HEARD.
WILL THIS HAPPEN.
WHILE THEY BE RELEASED OR COD
THE ORDERS BE BLOCKED?
>> DOJ IS FIGHTING.
THEY NEED TO FIGHT, WE’RE IN THE
FIGHT OF OUR LIVES RIGHT NOW.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NEEDS TO
APPEAL THE DECISIONS TAKE THEM
TO THE HIGHEST COURTS THE LOOK,
IF I WAS THE I.C.E. DIRECTOR, IF
I WAS THE I.C.E. DIRECTOR RIGHT
NOW, WHAT I WOULD DO A PRESS
RELEASE EVERY SINGLE DAY, TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO IS BEING
RELEASED WHAT THEIR CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS ARE, WHAT JUDGE BY
NAME ORDERED THAT RELEASE.
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY SHOULD OWN THOSE DECISIONS.
WHEN THEY REOFFEND, WHEN ANOTHER
CHILD IS RAPED OR SOME OTHER
U.S. CITIZEN IS RAPED OR
MURDERED CALL IT OUT.
THIS PERSON WAS RELATED BECAUSE
OF THIS JUDGE, ON THIS DATE,
THEY REOFFENDED ON THIS DATE.
WE NEED TO EDUCATE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
PETE: MAKES MY BLOOD BOIL,
ESPECIALLY CONSIDER TALK ABOUT
TESTING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
GRADE A LEVEL IN THESE
FACILITIES YET NOT GOOD ENOUGH
FOR FOLKS WHO BREAK OUR LAWS AND
COMMIT CRIMES.
REAL QUICK.
>> ZERO COVID DEATHS.
ZERO COVID DEATHS IN I.C.E.
DETENTIONS.
PETE: IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
COVID.
TOM, GREAT OP-ED AT FOXNEWS.COM.